sí por supuesto carlos en el mismo
momento en que fallece su majestad la
reina en ese mismo momento carlos ya es
el rey el nuevo rey del reino unido
sin duda otra cosa será la proclamación
que será mañana y otra cosa será la
coronación que será en unos meses no se
sabe todavía la señor correa es que
diferencia y precisamente interesa
proclamación y esa coronación la
proclamación es una proclamación
institucional por parte de las
autoridades en el alcalde de londres irá
el primer ministro la primera ministra
irán algunas personas destacadas del
parlamento del parlamento británico
es una cuestión institucional es una
cuestión de que de alguna manera se le
proclama rey después la lo que es la
coronación que ya digo será dentro de
unos meses pues se trata solamente de
darlo públicamente de hacer una cuestión
pública ante todos los ciudadanos y
hacer ya unos fastos en primer lugar
porque se tarda pues se tarda porque hay
que guardar el luto correspondiente
ahora no se puede celebrar el que esa
coronación sencillamente se le proclama
pero él ya es rey y desde el mismo
momento en que ha fallecido es el mismo
minuto que ha fallecido la reina